Є сьогодні вже багато людей,
які не хочуть викидати сміття будь-як.
Не хочуть користуватись
баками сортування, які є в містах,
тому що вони не впевнені,
що вміст поїде на переробку.
Люди хочуть мати гарантії.
І тоді є ми – організація,
яка надає такі гарантії.
По-перше, «Україна без сміття» – це рух.
Це рух за сортування відходів.
Тобто ми надаємо таку альтернативу людям:
вони можуть не постачати сміття
у довкілля, як сьогодні відбувається,
а вони можуть розділяти відходи вдома,
на корисні компоненти:
це пластик, скло, метали, полімери.
І здавати їх на переробку.
Якщо люди мають пластики,
які не підлягають переробці,
якщо в них є небезпечні відходи,
які треба відповідально утилізувати,
вони також можуть надавати
деякі такі відходи нам.
І ми віддамо їх на утилізацію шляхом
високотемпературного спалювання.
По-друге, ми є моделлю
соціального підприємництва.
Це така нова модель для України.
І у світі вона сьогодні активно розвивається.
Ми хочемо надати людям можливість
мати ту послугу, якої ще не існує.
Проєкт починав свою роботу в 2015 році.
Два роки тому ми відкрили першу станцію.
Вона була маленькою.
Приблизно 80 кв.м. Вона була у підвалі.
Але вже за три місяці сюди
почало приходити так багато людей,
що ми зрозуміли, що нам
не вистачає цієї площі.
Через рік ми відкрили вже
цю велику станцію сортування.
Якщо порівнювати,
скільки людей до нас приходило,
то в перші тижні роботи першої станції,
маленької – ми були неймовірно раді,
що до нас приходить
десь 20 людей на день.
Це було просто «вау!».
І нам здавалося, що це вже непоганий результат.
Але сьогодні, на цю станцію сортування,
на вихідних приходить щонайменше 500 людей.
Ви на екскурсію?
Тоді проходьте, будь ласка. Будемо розпочинати.
Хтось був уже у нас на станції?
Всі вперше? Клас!
Для того, щоб вторсировина поїхала на переробку,
її потрібно правильно відсортувати.
Усе, що люди нам приносять,
все повинне бути чисте і сухе, це обов'язково.
Далі: на що ми сортуємо сировину, які є фракції?
Макулатура, пластик, скло, метал, ґаджети.
Я народилася в Криму.
У дуже красивій місцевості.
І я ще пам'ятаю цей Крим,
коли він був бездоганно чистий.
Не було пластиків. Не було пластикових пляшок.
Але вже потім, коли я почала навчатись в університеті,
я поверталася до Криму відпочивати.
Я бачила зовсім іншу картину.
Коли почало з'являтися пластикове сміття,
яке нікуди не дівалось.
Яке дуже важко вивезти з прихованих місць
біля моря, за горами.
Я побачила цю різницю,
і це мені дуже «заболіло».
Коли я зрозуміла що відбувається
з відходами в Україні, я була шокована.
Увесь цей час я не розуміла,
куди дівається наше сміття,
яке ми викидаємо під будинками у баки.
Сьогодні я точно знаю,
що кожного дня ми погоджуємось з тим,
що комунальні установи
везуть наше сміття у довкілля.
Мало хто замислюється про наслідки
[шкоди] довкіллю, які спричиняють відходи.
Якщо брати пластики, то вони не розкладаються роками.
За нашого життя вони не розкладуться.
Сьогодні є і хлор-вмісні пластики і пластики,
які містять важкі метали.
Що відбувається з пластиком?
Він перетворюється на мікропластик.
І потім, з часом, він потрапляє до нас на стіл.
Сьогодні вже знаходять нано-пластик
у воді, у тваринах, у рибі –
потім ми їх споживаємо і теж накопичуємо.
Тому що важкі метали, важкі сполуки,
дуже важко вивести з організму.
Це призводить до імунних захворювань,
до онкологічних захворювань.
Тобто це така дуже сильна руйнівна дія.
Якщо говорити про шкідливий вплив звалищ,
то проблем звалищ декілька.
По-перше, звалище утворює токсичний фільтрат,
який просочується у підземні джерела.
Друга проблема – звалища горять.
Чому так відбувається?
Тому що в Україні захоронюється 50% органічних відходів.
Це мокрі відходи, які після захоронення,
з певним часом перетворюються на метан.
І він починає горіти в теплий період.
Україна стала кавовою державою.
Нам на кожному кроці пропонують «каву з собою».
Я все ж пропагую замінити одноразові стаканчики
на свою улюблену чашку.
Якщо є можливість не купувати
поліетиленові пакети, будь ласка, – не купуйте.
Візьміть з собою торбинку, авоську
будь-якого кольору, розміру, з малюнком чи без.
Свою улюблену.
Купіть, щоб вона завжди була з вами.
І наступне – чеки.
Зажди переживаю,
бо бачу скільки у нас викидається чеків.
Вони не переробляються.
Вони дуже шкідливі, як для людини,
так і для навколишнього середовища.
Не кладіть їх у кишені,
не кладіть у торбину
або пакет з продуктами харчування,
не давайте чеки в руки.
Запровадження відповідальної моделі сортування, сміттєпереробки, відповідального спалювання відходів
дозволяє зупини рух відходів у довкілля.
Станція сортування допомагає в цьому.
Тобто вона є платформою, яка дозволяє
людині на власному прикладі побачити,
як можна суттєво зменшити кількість сміття,
яке викидається у смітник.
У нас також є послуга «Досортування».
Люди, які просто зайняті, не мають
вільного часу, можуть прийти до нас,
віддати нам пакунки і заплатити за досортування,
яке здійснять наші консультанти або працівники.
У нас також нещодавно
з'явилася послуга «Пластик поштою».
У нас також є освітній напрямок – це платні екскурсії
для школярів або для дорослих.
Також у нас є спеціальна крамниця, де ми пропонуємо товари, які заміщують одноразове [споживання].
Тобто це велика кількість товарів,
які дозволяють вам
бути більш відповідальними у побуті щодня.
Друзі, я вам дуже дякую.
У нас вже відкрились ці двері.
Приходьте й приводьте друзів, приходьте з дітьми.
Це такий ще освітній міні-проєкт,
коли приходять і бачать, що тут відбувається.
Підписуйтесь на наші сторінки в соціальних мережах.
Нам так здається,
що одна людина – нічого.
Нам так кожного разу кажуть –
ви маленькі, і ви нічого не можете зробити.
Але знаєте, коли кожна «одна» людина,
відмовиться від стаканчиків і від пакетів,
ви собі не уявляєте, як це багато
для природи і для вашого здоров'я.
Це дуже багато. Тому це – маленький крок,
який починається з кожного з нас.
Коли ми створили першу станцію сортування,
через певний час схожі проєкти почали з'являтися в інших містах.
Можливо це сталося через те,
що і громадськість стала більш обізнаною.
Тобто людям важливе питання екології.
Тому що вони відчули, що це сильно впливає
на якість їхнього життя і на їхнє здоров'я.
Наше велике бажання – зробити таку правильну
революцію у сфері поводження з відходами,
яка б навела альтернативу.
Тобто на сьогодні ми маємо бізнес-структури,
які запроваджують моделі поводження з відходами,
комунальні установи.
А немає чогось іншого.
І ось це «інше» пропонуємо ми.
І ми бачимо, що насправді немає неможливих цілей.
Якщо в тебе є бачення, є бажання вирішити
якусь проблему таким креативним шляхом,
то з'являються компанії,
які хочуть тобі допомогти.
Люди, які хочуть брати у цьому участь.
І ми покажемо, мабуть,
навіть усьому світові,
модель того, як може бути
реалізована воля громадськості.